je m'appelle sylvain draps mais je suis
professeur de sciences sociales et dans
cette vidéo je ne vous parlerai pas du
brame du cerf mais bien de la
méthodologie des sciences sociales et
offrant semble un petit exercice sur la
question de départ je vous propose une
question à vous de me dire si c'est une
bonne question de départ si vous n'avez
pas encore vu la vidéo qui vous explique
comment identifier une bonne question de
départ je vous invite à la regarder
voici la proposition du jour
voici la réponse à cet exercice ce n'est
pas une bonne question de départ pour
une recherche en sciences sociales
tout d'abord il s'agit d'une question
fermée qui n'invitent pas à donner une
réponse explicative en plus la question
n'est pas réaliste parce que personne ne
sait prédire ce qui va se passer dans
l'avenir et a priori le clonage
numérique n'est pas un fait social mais
il est toujours possible d'aller
chercher un fait social en construisant
bien son objet d'étude vous dis à
bientôt pour d'autres exercices sur la
méthodologie des sciences sociales